blondes
stock up on these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead if you're
expecting guests around
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version I.E blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
gently melt that butter
caster sugar into the bowl
[Music]
let's give that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a bit lighter
slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make
it well in the middle
and sort of whisk
you see
it's already gone nice and blunt
love it
give that a really good mix
and a secret with the butter be slightly
warm sort of it melts the sugar
they're nice and smooth lovely
a teaspoon of vanilla extract in
next lightning whisk in two whole eggs
just give them a little beat
this is such a delicious recipe yes so
simple whisking the eggs looking for
that nice sort of Rich textured smooth
paste
you can see why we call these blondies
beautiful next teaspoon of baking powder
baking powder in then half a teaspoon of
baking soda
aerates the mixture and gives it that
little tartness you'll see the sort of
Rise instantly the minute they hit the
oven
and then your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it occasionally
no lumps half flour in
and then the other half in you'll feel
it sort of almost go nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flowering stages this stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the Whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon
next I want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies dried
cranberries they bake beautifully but it
gives the Blondie a really nice sort of
chewy sweetness in the center next and
white chocolate
[Music]
I'm not going to grate it just chop it
up just slice it like little bits of
shrapnel
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
now chocolate in lovely fold that in I
want a nice even distribution of those
wonderful dried cranberries
don't over mix it I want to break up
and chocolate
nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate
see the chocolate there'll be parts of
the chocolate in the oven that will
actually melt it'll be like little pools
of white melted chocolate in the center
now baking tray
small little knob of butter
and the grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just over
extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
grease proof
allows me to maximize on the white
chocolate inside the mix my grease with
paper the chocolate can melt and almost
stick to the tray so the paper is just a
really nice insurance policy secondly we
want that rise and that sort of
crispness now with the mix get your
spatula all the way around I don't see
anything left in that bowl
position the ball over your tray
nice and carefully
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one and then just
take the back of a spatula go into the
corners push and come back into the
middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it Cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
Blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise it's nice and crisp
on that soft gooiness in the center
make your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
foreign
Edge on the outside and that sort of
soft gooey Center
leave that to cool down and it's going
to sort of firm up and wrinkle but it'll
stay nice and gooey in the center once
it's cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
of watching blondies a fantastic easy
treat to have on hand for yourself or to
share
raspberry milfoy
desserts should always have that wow
factor and this dish is incredibly
simple to prepare but it tastes and
looks absolutely stunning
first off puff pastry you can buy
fabulous puff pastry now a non-stick
baking tray and just lay the puff pastry
on the tray I want to get the top of the
puff pastry caramelized I'm going to
dust it in icing sugar
number three means
a thousand layers
just lightly dust the top of the puff
pastry with iced sugar we're going to
start off in a hot oven at 220.
for the first six or seven minutes and
then 10 minutes
at 190 into the oven
now for the filling
fresh vanilla
cream in
and start whisking I want the cream
whisked nice and thick but look to all
that nice fresh vanilla seeds in there
next
a nice scraping of orange zest
orange liqueur
don't whisk that in fold it in
and that stops the cream from separating
them
lovely
now take that out of the bowl
and put it into a Piping Bag unwrap over
your hands
in a way that you're creating this
little pocket
snip off the end nozzle
thin
load up
the bag just
twist slowly
There's No Air
the bag
is nice and full
and fun nice chill your gorgeous vanilla
and orange cream in the fridge until
you're ready to pipe it
wow
it's beautiful there's the layers there
that's the the Milford Pub gently lift
it up onto the board
a size into three
serrated edge knife
wow
beautiful start deciding on how you're
going to layer it that bit there that's
nice and firm for my base that's nice
and decorative for the top and that bit
there for the middle
take out your cream
and put a little touch of cream there
and that just sticks that down
stops it from sliding
pipe very carefully
a nice thin layer of cream around the
outside and come back into the middle
beautiful
now the rice with
sit them
two by two
now this layer
I'll turn it upside down and put the
caramelized part of pastry on top of the
raspberries
every time I get to put one of these
together it's like a sort of little
jewelry box again cream
squeeze from the back of the bag
so you've got control they're asked with
two by two
I just want to put another layer of
cream on top those raspberries because I
want some height with my final layer
oh I just want to dive in there
put the lid on it
and push that down
there you have a beautiful stunning
a dessert to die for and like all the
dishes in my ultimate cookery course I
guarantee it will taste as Sensational
as it looks
caramelized figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful Rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in rows take
some Rosemary and just peel that down
get that really nice fragrant stem get
your scissors trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp Point bring your three figs
together
and just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently Rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stock will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
the figs with icing sugar then coat them
with a generous splash of Blossom with
vinegar leave them to sit there for five
minutes they sort of marinade I know it
sounds odd to use vinegar in your
dessert but trust me it gives the dish a
fantastic sweet and sour taste I'm gonna
make a really nice caramel four or five
tablespoons of sugar now flatten that
out and get it nice and even when the
sugar is even caramel Cooks evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in the one thing you
don't do is shake the pan rapidly
and sit almost like sort of a lake
defrosting and it's hitting to the
center bubbling it's still not dark
enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking lovely
take that off the gas another butter in
there
gently whisk in
the butter is cooling the camel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe Olay
next add a lug of the balsamic vinegar
beautiful
for that nice dark richness
of a camel a little touch of water in
there
that way the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the camel back on the heat take
a fix and sort of place them in gently
lovely
and then just added all that lovely
little marinade
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar and butter vinegar
so tasty
based those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside and the
Fig sort of just absorbs the caramel
delicious so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
they smell
is incredible
onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that camera
now dash the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese the
freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
I'm gonna finish that now
it seems zest
and then
some little nibbed hormones
and the rich creamy Jam texture of the
Fig
with a ricotta
brilliant that is an amazing way of slow
roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]